oh that's weird I didn't know he was  here Peter Peter is that you Pete  how strange there's nobody here  [Music]  a bit of a slob isn't he all brilliant  men are  [Music]  hey everyone it's a jungle out there had  to beat an old lady with a stick to get  these crannies thank you now then  everybody sit down  and we can say grace  Norman will you do the honors  why Peters you're bleeding oh yeah I  stepped off a curb and got clipped by  one of those bike messengers let me see  oh my goodness  oh that looks awful it's nothing I'll  get the first-aid kit this is the boys  first Thanksgiving in this department  and we are going to do things properly  how did you say that happened bike  messenger knocked me down  you'll excuse me I've got to be going  why something is coming to my attention  are you all right I'm fine just fine  thank you mrs. Parker everyone enjoy the  fruitcake  you